in today's Dynamic an Ever evolving
business landscape effective strategic
management is Paramount for
organizations aiming to achieve success
as Industries continue to undergo rapid
Transformations driven by technological
advancements changing consumer behaviors
and Global Market shifts the role of a
strategic manager has become more
critical than ever in this video on
strategic manager roadmap we will cover
What is strategy management future scope
and career opportunities required skill
of a strategic manager roles and
responsibilities of a strategic manager
step-by-step guide to human strategic
manager but before we begin let me ask
you a quick question so which of the
following best defined strategics
management option A is the process of
day-to-day operational decision making
within organization option b is the
analysis of competitive tactics in order
to mimic their success option Z is the
systematic planning execution and
evaluation of an organization's
long-term goals and objectives of Hindi
is the implementation of short-term
plans to achieve immediate financial
gains alright now you can pause this
video and answer in the comment section
below so let's move on with the first
topic which is what is a strategy
management so strategy management is
like playing game but in a business
setting just like how players plan their
moves to win a game companies use
strategy management to plan how they
will achieve their goals and stay ahead
in the industry imagine yourself a
leader of a team playing a soccer match
to win you need to have a plan right you
decide or your team will play who will
be in what position and how you will
react to other team's move this planning
and decision making is a strategy so
basically strategy management is the
process that companies use to plan
execute and monitor their strategies to
achieve their long-term goals it
involves making decisions and taking
actions to ensure that a company is
moving in the right direction and making
the most effective use of its resources
it includes setting goals companies
establish clear and specific objectives
they want to achieve over a certain
period these goals provide a sense of
right direction and purpose for the
company then there is analyze the
current situation the Second Step
involves analyzing the current situation
through methods like SWOT analysis this
includes evaluating the company's
strengths weaknesses opportunities and
threats additionally examining available
resources like budget time and staff
AIDS in Penning a strategy course
followed then there is execution once
the plan is in place the company puts it
into action this involves implementing
the strategies and initiatives outlined
in the plan such as launching new
products entering new markets or
improving operation process the next is
monitoring and evaluation companies
regularly track their progress towards
the goals set in the plan they gather
data analyze results and access whether
they are on track or need to make
adjustments this step helps to identify
any issues early and make necessary
changes now coming to the Future scope
and career opportunities for a strategic
manager first would be Financial
benefits so strategy managers often
learn competitive salaries due to their
critical role in rhyming business
success as companies value strategic
decision makings Professionals in this
role can negotiate attractive
compensation packages so the first point
would be Financial benefit now coming to
the second career growth strategy
managers have a wide career trajectory
including opportunities to move into
senior leadership roles Like Chief
strategy officer their exposure to
various business functions and decision
making equips them with skills for
broader manager positions then there is
industry versatility strategy managers
gain versatile skills applicable across
Industries enhancing employability and
Mobility they can transition into
Consulting entrepreneurship or even
specialize in certain sectors then there
is networking advantages so strategy
managers interact with top Executives
and stakeholders expanding their
Professional Network for future
prospects so this gives them a
opportunity to network with top leaders
alright so this was about the future
scope and career opportunities of a
strategic manager now coming to the
career or job opportunities choosing
this field opens doors to multitude of
exciting career paths as you embark on
this journey you can easily opt for
rules such as strategy manager product
strategist research investigator
business analyst project management
coordinator Management Consultant Chief
strategy officer investment analyst risk
analyst supply chain manager corporate
development manager e-commerce
strategist so there are variety of
careers in this strategic manager
Journey all right now let's have a look
at some required skills to become a
strategic manager so structural and
logical thinking so structural and
logical thinking is the ability to
dissect complex situations and identify
key elements second would be problem
solving in decision making it is the
capacity to tackle integrate challenges
by breaking them into manageable
components then there is analytical
proficiency it is a skill to interpret
data identify patterns and draw
meaningful insights it is a very
important skill then there is
communication and collaboration
effective communication to convince
strategies to diverse stakeholders is a
skill of our strategic manager then
there is risk management risk management
is a skill to access potential risk
associated with strategic decisions then
there is time and Resource Management a
person with this skill allocates
resources wisely to maximize efficiency
and outcome then there is ethical
leadership ethical leadership uphold
ethical standards while formulating and
executing strategies so these are the
required skills to become a strategic
manager so if a person wants to become a
strategic manager these are the
must-have skills all right now let's
understand the roles and
responsibilities of a strategic manager
so first would be developing long-term
business strategies to support growth
and revenue second would be identifying
weaknesses or opportunities in ongoing
strategies and making recommendation
based on internal and external factors
the next is analyzing and accessing
internal processes and market trends to
find areas of improvement or competitive
Advantage after that there is leading
and managing one to several corporate
departments to meet specific challenges
and goals next is evaluating potential
threats and establishing plans to
minimize them through the risk
management so these were some of the
rules and responsibilities of a
strategic manager so as we have
understood about skills roles and
responsibilities over Strategic
Management now let's move on to have a
look at the step-by-step guide to become
a strategic manager so the first step
would be degree in engineering or
business so beginning your journey with
a bachelor's degree is either
engineering or business sets the stage
for your path towards become a strategic
manager this foundational education
provides issue with Essential Knowledge
in both technical aspects and business
operations in engineering you learn
problem solving and analytical skills
which are vital for making effective
decisions in business you grasp Concepts
like how companies work market trends
and financial principles this combined
understanding equips you to tackle
complex challenges make informed choices
and create successful strategies coming
to the next step which is develop
strategy management skills building
strategy management skills is like
creating a strong foundation for
strategic manager think of it as
learning tools that help you succeed in
your room picture critical thinking as a
way to understand tricky situations and
decision making as a skill to make smart
choices problem solving is like finding
creative answers to problems and
Leadership is about guiding your team
towards important goals these abilities
are like toolkit that every strategic
manager needs to do in their job helping
them navigate the complex world of
business and confidence is another skill
alright now coming to the third step
which is online certification or courses
so enroll in online courses
certification specific to Strategic
Management these programs offers
targeted knowledge and practical
insights to enhance your strategic
thinking capabilities you can opt for
post-graduate program in business
analysis by simplylearn post graduate
program in business analysis tailored
made for individuals aspiring to embark
on fulfilling career in business
analysis whether we are new to the field
and eager to grasp business analysis
techniques or an experienced analyst
aiming to master the Cutting Edge tools
and Frameworks and raised by agile teams
this program is your ultimate Gateway
dive into the comprehensive learning
gain hands-on experience and elevate
your expertise in the dynamic realm of
business analysis your journey to
professional growth Starts Here coming
to the next which is master's degree in
strategy management consider pursuing a
master degree in strategy management or
a related field this Advanced education
deepens your understanding of strategy
Concepts and equips you for leadership
roles then there is gain in work
experience this is the next step so
working in various roles across
different departments to gain a
comprehensive understanding of how our
business operates this is work
experience this diverse experience
builds a holistic perspective essential
for Strategic Management so again work
experience is another important thing
while moving on a journey to become a
strategic manager all right next step is
stay updated staying up to date is like
keeping your compass pointed in the
right direction imagine being aware of
the latest trends in your industry
understanding when the market shifts and
being in the know about Newton this
knowledge is like a secret weapon that
helps you create plans that perfectly
match the ever-changing world of
business it's like having a map that
guides your strategies through the
twists and turns of the business
landscape ensuring you're always on the
path to success last one is apply for
role of strategy manager yes as you
accumulate experience and knowledge seek
out opportunities for the role of a
strategy manager craft a compelling
resume that highlights your skills
qualifications and achievements so by
following all these steps you can easily
become a strategy manager so as you
finish this video on roadmap about
Strategic Management you have learned
how to handle changes in the business
world this journey doesn't stop it keeps
going and needs you to be flexible and a
good leader remember to use new ideas
work together with others and always
keep your main goal in mind so alright
guys with that we have come to the end
of this video If you like this video
please give it a thumbs up I hope it
really helped you all thanks for
watching stay safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here